[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and with us now being past the halfway
point of the undoing
i think things are slowly starting to
fit into place
the episode does clear up the big
cliffhanger from last week
however it also makes it seem like
something else could be going on
that could indeed tie into it now when
we last left grace
she was being shown the cctv footage
that placed her next to where elena's
body lay
though in any other investigation she
would now be one of the prime suspects
the police let her go without asking too
many questions
grace states that she was simply having
a walk at the time
and the officers they must have taken
her at her word
this shows that they're putting all
their eggs in one basket
and completely overlooking the fact that
grace could have carried it out
in addition to this elena's husband also
had a motive too
and i think this sole focus on jonathan
will actually cause
issues in the case as they clearly
haven't exhausted all
options now though it could be possible
that grace is
actually the one who carried out the
murder there is another option entirely
that i haven't discussed yet
on our last video youtube user la musing
said that grace may have not committed
the murder
but she could have indeed come across
jonathan carrying it out
the comment really peaked my interest
and the more i've thought about it
the more i think that the user might be
right they went on to say
what she is blanking out is not that she
committed the murder
but that she witnessed him committing it
and her mind cannot accept the fact that
the man she loves is a monster
despite her background and skills in
psychology
she literally could not see the truth
now this of course ties in with her
passion from the first episode
who discussed her own husband and the
issues in their marriage
grace was very quick to say that the
patient's problem was that she was
unable to see her husband for what he
truly was
and i think grace herself is indeed
showing signs of that too
from what we've seen in these four
episodes she's very prone to
hallucinations
and we learn that she also goes and
walks to ground herself
it's a phrase that comes with the idea
that the person doing this is trying to
get back in touch with reality
and thus they must collect their own
thoughts which grace likely does on her
walks
so we have this motif that grace is
indeed prone to slip into certain
fantasies
and that she may also block things out
that could cause her dream life to fall
apart
i definitely think that this could be
what happened in the show but there are
of course other things that we do have
to discuss
now another big suspect was franklin
however i think this episode pretty much
confirms what we said last week
we did say that it would make no sense
for him to kill elena and not jonathan
and in this episode he also pays for the
character's bail
in addition to this he pointed the
family in the direction of their
attorney
so for me it just doesn't line up now we
see a much darker side to him in this
episode
and he pretty much threatens the
headmaster and calls himself
a car a [ __ ] record set i can't
that that bit did kill me now franklin
admits to being unfaithful to grace's
mother
and we'll go into this in more detail
later in the video
whilst this shows the character in a new
light he also tells jonathan that he
thinks he killed eleanor
which i don't think he would say if he
had done it himself
juxtaposing this fernando elena's
husband
acts really weird this episode i think
things do point towards him slightly for
the same reason that they point away
from franklin
fernando invites jonathan in to spend
time with his daughter
and if the character believed that he
had killed his wife
this just seems like a very odd thing to
do if fernando
did indeed murder eleanor then he would
know that jonathan
wasn't the one who carried it out and
thus would feel fine about having him in
the house
though he is angry at first he comes
around very quickly
i think anyone else in that position
would have kicked hugh's little head in
now fernando's alibi
was that he was with his son but we did
see in flashbacks that he came across
grace and jonathan getting it on
due to the time of night she was killed
his son would likely be asleep
and therefore i'm not sure if we can put
too much weight into his alibi
that also thematically ties in with the
show's overall narrative
which is that husbands have things that
they hide from the world
take him away boys i've i've cracked the
case
now as for the plot of the episode we
pretty much get grace drifting around
asking questions
and she slowly starts to trust her
husband more and more
she goes back to badger to ask more
about how he feels over his innocence
visits her father several times to get
him to intervene
and continues to live at his house with
her son henry
we discover that eleanor was obsessed
over grace and
even made a mural to her all of this
just gets on top of the protagonists
throughout the episode
and she ends up fainting and becomes
hospitalized
henry also says sorry to eleanor's son
and they do
heavily dig into this henry has been
someone that i think has started to seem
more and more like a suspect
the longer that we've gone on in the
series like his mother
henry lives in a bubble and it could be
possible that when faced with what his
father did
he decided to kill elena in order to
stop her from breaking up his parents
marriage
we did a much deeper dive on this on our
last video
but the fact he says sorry could hinder
him apologizing for killing the boy's
mother
he plays it up as being something that's
part of the school's motto
but anyone who went to school and had to
deal with these kinds of things
knows that you don't really pay that
much attention to them
henry wasn't at the party and at the
time of eleanor's murder his whereabouts
are unaccounted for
those are kind of the minor suspects i
think and if you're enjoying the video
so
far then don't forget to subscribe to
the channel as we do videos like this
each and every day
we will of course be covering the rest
of the series we're also doing
breakdowns on his dark materials and the
mandalorian
so there's plenty of reasons to stick
around now last time whilst
i did bang on about how innocent
jonathan was i've slowly started to
change my mind
early on he mentions that he's estranged
from his family
and this could be because they actually
know the truth about what he's like
he also admits to having another affair
and the signs that he's not who he says
he is
are becoming more and more clear when
talking to his lawyer haley
we also see her standing in front of a
picture of two shadows
reflecting one another symbolically this
could hint at him having two sides
and throughout our breakdowns we pointed
out how there are often two figures
used to convey this idea of duality
going to fernando's house
is also a really odd move especially as
it's breaking a condition of his bail
the guy also goes on tv to do a gun girl
over his infidelity
and he still seems to be obsessed with
eleanor as he admits to loving her
as mentioned by his co-workers jonathan
would play up having eleanor
and this is what got him fired in the
first place so
him playing it up to the press
definitely feels in line with that
and haley even says to him that he has
the capability to mesmerize people
not only did he mesmerize grace he also
got me
and i think the fact that he's estranged
from his family has had several affairs
uh is it's just made it so obvious
now franklin admits to cheating on
grace's mother and he says because
jonathan reminded him of himself
he took an instant dislike to him
because of this he said that he believes
jonathan killed eleanor
i think this does tell the audience
what's really going on with him
his dna is at the scene of the crime no
one else's is
and he ends the episode by trying to
come off as some sort of victim
his final words are that he has some
idea of who was behind the crime
and i think that he might actually try
to throw grace under the bus
if he was indeed at the crime scene when
it was carried out
anyway that concludes the episode and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it as well as what your theories are
if you enjoy this video then please drop
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of last week's entry which
will be linked at the end
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase 2 box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random at the end of the month so make
sure you get involved
going to support the channel and get to
see contents early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video you
be the best
i mean paul i'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
do
you